George always appreciate your time I
guess I'll just start with what's the
NFLPA official position on this letter
from Adolpho birch in the NFL good
morning to you Ross and I wish we were
both at Copacabana beach with Dan at the
moment but you know certainly we were a
little bit taken aback with the tone of
that letter certainly there are areas
that we can choose to disagree with the
league we have a lot of respect for the
game our players have a lot of respect
for what they do as professionals but
you know I think that that letter in
particular cross the line of what is
professional conduct as it relates to
dealing with with your players and you
know we've always taken the position
that the NFL needs to step up and
provide any evidence that they have
beyond just a report that has now been
recanted or was immediately recanted and
they haven't done that yet so for them
to make a mountain out of this mole hill
is unfortunate and it's disappointing
but ultimately it's our job to represent
our players and that's what we'll do so
George's for the people that are just
happening on this thing basically the
NFLPA agrees that if there's credible
evidence in terms of a violation then
their players should sit for the
interview you're saying and the players
have contended that there is not
credible evidence whereas the league is
saying in their opinion there is
credible evidence is that really what
this is coming down to uh I think that's
a pretty good explanation so when the
report first came out I guess it was in
December there were all these names
dropped in that report and you know the
most notable one obviously was Payton
inning these four players were named in
some way by general
names Charlie sly as soon as that report
was public he came out and recanted
everything and the NFL has contended
that based on that soul piece of
evidence as far as we know that the
players need to submit to not only an
investigation but an interview and all
sorts of other things we don't believe
that that is outlined in the CBA now
ultimately when you are in a position
like we are now we're going to support
the players and whatever they decide to
do they can it's always been their
choice as to whether or not to proceed
with the interviews or not the union is
going to represent them if they decide
to move forward the union will be there
if they decide to not sit down for the
interview the union will be there for
them as well but what advice are you
giving them George well I mean like
everything else so in any other
situation that we've gone through over
the last six or seven years these are
your rights these are the decisions that
you have to choose from and these are
the consequences for each and risks for
each of those decisions so again we've
talked about the rights we don't believe
that the league has a right to impose
you know the players coming in for an
interview based on nothing that is clear
we certainly don't think they have any
right to impose discipline based on
what's out there there is nothing out
there but obviously the risks to and the
consequences to them denying that if you
take the league at their word is that
they'll be suspended indefinitely in
miss games which will obviously lead to
another fight of some sort down the road
we don't want to be in that position I
certainly hope the league doesn't want
to be in that position it's
disappointing that we're on the eve of
another great NFL season and the
headlines are not about what's happening
on the field but what's happening off
the
is the nflpa and the NFL in talks to try
to work something out here that's a
great question we would love to have
been in discussions to try to have this
thing resolved months ago that has not
been the case it look Ross this is not
our first go-around with this regime in
the league office they did the same
exact thing if you remember in bounty
they did the same exact thing when they
violated the CBA with Ray Rice now
clearly they happen to have gotten a
couple of court cases go in their favor
recently but that doesn't mean that the
law is a good substitute for
professionalism and a level of behavior
that is deemed you know to respect the
players of the National Football League
that's just who they are this is what
the job is and and we will stand up for
our players no matter what George
refresh my memory has there been players
suspended for not cooperating or not
talk I know far I've got you know fine
50 grand or something for not
cooperating is there any precedent for
guys to be suspended and miss football
games for not agreeing to talk to the
league no there is no precedent for such
a thing and you know Saints fans know
all too well what happened to their
franchise obviously Patriots fans are
still mad and I think will always be mad
about you know the fact that tom is
going to miss the first four games of
this season and and now Packers fans and
steeler fans are getting a taste of you
know when you have a league office that
doesn't kind of respect the rules of
engagement this is what happens so there
isn't there isn't a precedent for that
we certainly don't think that this is
the the right thing to do but you know
we
we will do what we have to do given what
the players decide here in the next
couple of days talking with George
Atallah the NFLPA assistant executive
director of external affairs here on the
Dan Patrick show George based on the NFL
exonerating Peyton Manning they clearly
are saying that they don't believe
Charlie sly to be credible yet they
still want to interview these guys so
are they just doing this because they
can I mean is this just kind of a power
play you know let's say they have two
interviewer will suspend them because we
can because they can't be that concerned
about these guys actually taking peds
because they just exonerated Payton yeah
that's a great point I mean that is that
is what logic and reason would dictate
that you have no evidence you have not
produced any evidence and you've just
exonerated Payton for the you know
arguably who was a more notable subject
of the documentary than any of the four
players that we're talking about so
logic and reason does not usually
dictate the behavior of the league
office oftentimes you know again we
would much rather be in a world where
we're talking about issues that are
about to happen on the field you know as
much as people don't like the preseason
there's a lot to like about young
players getting a chance and teams
trying to rebuild and all of the things
that you want to talk about heading into
the football season this is not high on
our list of things to discuss but here
we are so two questions if the players
decide they're not going to interview I
guess number one would be what is the
what does the nflpa do then do you file
some sort of legal injunction or
something that I'm glad I didn't go to
law school for or do you pay the players
money do you pay the players money that
are missing out on if they're suspended
well there are certainly legal options
if the players decide that they do not
want to sit down for the interview you
know Ross you and I have talked to know
x I'm not a lawyer we have a very
capable internal and external legal
counsel who whose job it is to worry
about those things you know I think
there are certainly recourses that we
can take to protect their rights if they
don't want to do that again our advice
to the players has always been these are
your rights know what they are you do
not have to sit down for this because
the drug policy do not call for a
submission of interviews if there isn't
any credible evidence and if you decide
to go through with it great if you
decide not to we're always up for a
fight last question George and this
one's totally off topic but we're going
to talk about Marcell Dareus a little
bit and his suspension does the NFLPA
have an official position on marijuana
testing in the league yeah the official
position is that we have a collectively
bargained drug policy that still
maintains that the banned substance
certainly we made some progressive
changes in 2014 when we sign the new
drug policies that you know elevated the
number of nanograms and offenses that
you needed in order to get suspended but
our focus as a union is more on the
medical usage in the scientific usage
going forward how can we treat that
substance I think we might have just
lost in that area yeah I said how can we
treat that substance as potentially one
that that deals with the pain management
issue that our players go through I mean
I think that's where our union is going
to be from this point forward but every
player knows that they have to adhere to
to the program pretty strictly and you
know that's that's where we are George
really appreciate the time thanks for
coming aboard this morning my pleasure
and hope to talk to you soon there he is
George Atallah the day
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience